okay I'm answering the Internet if you
could be any character from a TV show
who would you be I would be Xaro who is
the one president who you would want to
get shit-faced with Bill Clinton you've
been put in charge of running heck the
alternative what the afterlife for
people not evil enough for hell what's
the first torture you would design being
licked by my son's three legged
idiosyncratic German Shepherd his name
is Hamlet we are babysitting for Hamlet
he's amazing would you rather not be
able to watch the last 10 minutes of
every TV show movie or the last 10
minutes of every sporting event I will
go with sporting event
would you rather throw up throw up every
time someone says McDonald's or wear a
fedora for the rest of your life and if
anybody asks about if you have to
sincerely say I just like it the way it
looks I would wear the hat all right
would you rather go back 18 year to an
18 year old knowing everything you now
know or get 1 million dollars I would
love to know what I know now I think
youth is wasted on the young would you
rather walk with a roller blade on your
left shoe for the rest of you who the
hell thinks of that Hornet would you
like to walk with a rollerblade on your
left shoe for the rest of your life or
having a little port a person walking in
front of you walking slightly slower
than you want to do for the rest of your
life the little person has a bad temper
I would make friends with that little
person can you watch one actors movie
for the rest of your life who would you
be picking Spencer Tracy you don't know
who Spencer Tracy
look him up would you lose all your own
memory or never be able to make a new
one never be able to make a new one
would you rather have a dog's
personality and a cat's body I hate cats
would you rather be able to eat as much
as you want without getting fat or never
have to pay for a meal again I would
like to eat without getting fat because
I'm on my way would you can you shoot me
here because this is really ugly
would you rather date a girl who laughs
at everything or nothing laughs at
everything which fictional character
would you love to beat the [ __ ] out of I
have no idea I don't because I don't
want to hurt my hand would you rather go
to heaven or become a ghost on earth
after you die I'd like to go to heaven
who is the one celebrity you would want
to at your funeral oh okay
ah see yeah you have one three-throw
shot and if you make it you get a
million dollars if you miss it you can
never text again oh I would take the
shot if you what I was would I hit I
would hit the shot if you if you were
stuck in a food and had to eat your way
out of it what would it be
Oh my cheeseburger from the burger joint
in the lobby of the Parker Meridien
Hotel on 57th Street New York City would
you rather be blind or [ __ ] blind
what is the fiercest animal you think
you could take on in a fight what is the
fiercest animal you think you could take
on in a fight a parakeet
would you rather have to eat all the
hair every time you get a haircut or eat
all the fingernails
every time you clip your nails oh come
on that is that is just disgusting would
you rather be filthy rich in 1900 or
poor now poor now if you had to pick one
person to be the ambassador for the
human race to meet all the aliens I
answered this question Muhammad Ali
would you rather stub your toe get a
brain freeze or bite your tongue cheek
randomly three times a week
Oh would you rather stub your toe No
get a brain for brain freeze I'd go over
the brain freeze because the others hurt
a lot would you rather go blind by the
age 20 or 5 3 with a full I would go
bald